ne me quitte pas il faut oublier tout
jacques brel est ce que oui ou non on
vous reverra chanter sur une scène de
music hall je propose je crois pas j'ai
pas envie et je ne compte pas refaire ma
communion solennelle non je ne compte
pas
j'ai pas envie tiens jacques brel sur
scène c'est donc fini et c'est tant pis
pour nous mais brel n'est pas mort pour
autant
et c'est précisément ce qu'a voulu
prouver le metteur en scène canadien
denis euros en réalisant un film dont le
titre anglais signifie à peu près brel
est vivant il habite paris et il va bien
merci
il s'agit d'une comédie musicale ou
jacques brel joue son propre rôle mais
vous la presque totalité de ses chanson
est interprétée en anglais par un
chanteur célèbre mort shuman et par une
chanteuse un peu moins connu du moins en
france
eli stone
oh
je vais bien comprise et ce qu'ils
racontent et je parle l'anglais comme un
veau alors il est vrai sans aucun
quoique ça m'aurait fait quelque chose
c'est assez récent là mais là non
la ram cette deuxième en réalité dans ce
film jacques brel ne fait que quelques
apparitions symbolique mais il était
difficile d'imaginer une histoire basée
sur ses chansons sans qu'il enchante une
lui-même
alors regardez bien c'est un événement
pour la première fois depuis huit ans
jacques brel chantent en direct ne me
quitte pas
ne me quitte pas il faut oublier d'où de
s'oublier
qui s'enfuit déjà oublié le temps des
malentendus et le temps perdu à savoir
comment oublier ces harkis tué par voie
coûte pourquoi que du bonheur
le quitte pas
ne me quitte pas de jacques brel
est ce que oui ou non on verra je
sentais sur une scène de logique rock
nous je crois vraiment qu non je crois
je crois vraiment je ne compte pas
refermé il est normal de chanter le
matin dans sa salle de bain parce qu'on
est heureux parce qu'on est malheureux
mais ça n'est pas normal du tout de
chanter devant des gens aussi
j'ai chanté presque 20 ans et avant
chaque tour de chant j'ai vomi et j'ai
vomi de peur que ça fait vomir la vraie
peur quand on a peur physiquement aussi
on a tendance à vomir et j'ai vomi et
quand j'avais deux matinées soir et j'ai
vomi trois fois avant de peur si on n'a
pas peur c'est qu'on aime pas quand on
se met tous lu devant une dame pour la
première fois un homme qui n'est pas
mort de trouille c'est qu'il n'aime pas
la dame j'ai pas envie l'ennui
j'ai pas envie de pleurer je veux plus
parler
je tâcherai la de regarder danser
sourire et d'écouté je souhaitais cuir
il laisse moi de venir nombre de nombre
non
deux témoins l'ombre de ton chien mais
une qui tu ne me quitte pas
je ne compte pas refermé